the house to go and rest but it's hot
this is what it all started I can't
believe it's finally happen like for
those two you bros who don't know
I'm Nisha it's what started this channel
without this game without amnesia I
probably wouldn't be where I am with
YouTube to be fully honest there's a lot
of there's so much hype on this game
there's a lot of pressure it's not made
by the original frictional games guys
it's made by the Chinese room I play the
Chinese rooms mods I like them I think
they have great tasting horror and I
think I think they will do a good job
and I think they will do a good job by
keeping it different you know I don't
think it will I hope at least they
wouldn't followed it whatever you know
what let's just [ __ ] play I'm gonna
try to keep really immersed myself I
wanna I want to be as scared as I was
the first time I play amnesia which is
probably impossible but I want to try
you know I want to be in there I'm just
so excited to play this I've been
waiting for it to get dark out another
come on Sun go down already he who makes
a piece of himself removes himself from
the pain of being human
[Music]
daddy daddy please go I think that's a
pretty good request you know now that
I'm that reasonable for a daddy
the hell is that
can I move okay I don't want to move
I love this whoa
what it oh I might be some kind of
torture
[Applause]
can I move can't move can't move can't
move can't move gonna move get up daddy
I mean I'm daddy oh oh I don't know if I
wanna get up there but it begins and
begins
I can't move yet ah I'm not doing this
someone closed that door say ah doors
[Music]
okay well I mean tree I don't know why
but cata reminds me by a shot the whole
daddy and the scenery I guess here we go
it begins one small step for parents and
a giant pee stain for mankind why am i
spending am I supposed to be spinning I
doubt it maybe I am
ah no I think this is a now he's
spinning more and more in aren't you
I ordered an on spinning character okay
where are you
this place is huge hi I hug your hand
watch the blood pool between your legs
we lived long enough to see Edwin that
method on look I will take care of them
I love I promise you this why are you
searching this bed and that mask is
beautiful what did I do
okay let's keep going I'm gonna explore
everything cool I little girl little boy
or whatever whoa
but it's just a bowl it's banked but do
you know anything what was that
you go banked okay well that's no no
abuse what is with all these noises oh
it's the doors what Jeff [ __ ] just
happened
kids does not approve of that oh I don't
want to go up there they're gonna oh god
damnit I have to okay ah Jase know what
happened to my bowl anyway
shut up whatever okay
hi I'm great man great great man I'm not
a bad man I'm just what what the [ __ ]
I'm pretty sure I saw something whoa
what is going on here I thought it hi
Pat Hey look at me I'm dancing I'm
dancing I'm dancing I'm dancing I'm
dancing yeah you are
I'm afraid of click that because it's it
might all right Eddie you're coming with
me
I'm Paul yeah
you remind me a lot of someone I know
Teddy it's that so pants well that is
just [ __ ] great is it me I know this
hurts I know what's going on okay you
suppose it's like yeah - I don't I know
I don't shut up why did the music stop
oh it's over here
I said mask again ah well that was
surprisingly easy I don't like you
now I don't we're hiding daddy well god
damn you're annoying kids this day what
are you doing
[Music]
[ __ ] creepy man I can't jump um did I
just miss something over here let's go
away
thank you okay okay come out come out
wherever you are
are we back where are we I don't
understand
that's a sweet-ass goat somebody's
walking up there I don't like this dress
I really don't I didn't do it okay
well let's keep going down but shut up
oh sorry
sorry you know what kids are great kids
are great
who doesn't love a good kid in the okay
that is a woman with a pig head and this
is what I call a cake party in Sweden
lovely lovely lady nice texture
hello who's playing that piano no one is
playing no one is playing nobody's
playing no one is playing so sorry about
that little did that just fall down okay
that's fine that is some sweet assets
okay hmm no I thought it was I don't
know if the father is in this game the
developers are probably really tired of
that [ __ ] I'm tired of those paintings
please [ __ ] replicas all over the
place oh hell no dear lamp make that
phone not call oh it's one of those
sweet-ass retro ones okay okay
haha hello precious eagle cactus fruit
spouting random [ __ ] it's not gonna help
you idiot
keep telling taps don't worry I'm on
your side Terence there you are
hey Your Honor my press you look fancy
thanks Pierce I know I got a place yeah
look at that look at this look at my
butt yeah yeah
well why can't I go what how did I just
do
did I just solve a puzzle through sheer
genius Ness or luck
whatever same thing I think I did I just
wanted to take the gun like a gun in
amnesia let's [ __ ] shoot the brow oh
cool cool it's like a secret room
thingamajiggy you [ __ ] brats god I
hate you you're gonna get for this
they were running with such swag too
well I taught him well at least those
little [ __ ]
that mask was not there I pretty [ __ ]
sure okay
all righty it seems that someone was
doing some [ __ ] up [ __ ] this dawning
people this age of reason an empire
grown fat right for the bleeding right
for the blaring huh what did that do I
don't know Comfort I'm not wearing any
shoes because why the hell am i okay
this house is very strange oh oh I'm so
sorry so so very very sorry
that is a sweet-ass force it's not
[ __ ] eating out another horse okay Wow
survival of the fittest I guess that is
a sweet scenery that why the horses keep
eating each other I don't know why I'm
clapping but I feel like I did something
well I don't know if you bros remember
the original amnesia but you don't see
the monster until like an hour or 40
minutes into the game which is I don't
know
I think amnesia did better than any
horror game I ever played is pacing and
you know God never mind never mind who's
yelling like that what did I that was
not even a sentence kids whoa why was I
not invited
god damn it every time okay
[Music]
oh no oh no oh no oh Mary no smell the
flowers aah what the park what happened
what happened sorry
we're going down to a town which is
funky old you pieces of [ __ ] but I get
how do they you know what there are
other room
other great great rooms well I just came
high chair whoa nice you mask what are
you going to me
oh it shakes okay let's go here then
what does that make it I must say my
dear man you look awful yes I I seem to
have picked up something rather nasty in
message your great factory your
charities it is wonderful a drink do you
know me
no you none of my children yeah trapped
under bar below us the machine is found
in his blue light Mossad the bulkheads
are down the children are engaged if you
help me I can help you release them but
father I know commanders bring the
flooding and restart the great engines
where should I go hello hello
I like his voice acting fine
well nope not a big fan of alright we're
out again
I hate them so much I feel like this
game is gonna be one of those games that
will make you never want to have babies
Oh or dinosaurs what is that oh oh it's
a it's a giant and Theodore yes oh is
that so I can this should pig
whoa why are you so angry Tommy okay
well I wasn't expecting it
Hey look at that hey good cool
what is this hippopotamus the hip hop a
vertebrae
they call me the hip hop the Potamus
feels like all the fossil arrests
I can move grizzly I wish grizzly was a
friend of mine I think we could have
been friends you and me god damn it
crystal you are a genius high-five I am
solving all these pot hey butterflies
I'm solving puzzles with that hey Hector
I see I'm really sorry you can't come
with me what are you doing what I am you
can't throw I was like this game god
damn it
oh well seems like most objects you
can't really [ __ ] with I am going to go
did you for rotating sink
what is this yes of course I'm a genius
Oh No oh no was I supposed to do that
hello what am I doing with my life
sorry sorry there I mean to break your
friends and machines okay
so what's your story very interesting
whoa whoa I didn't see you sir I would
kiss you if I could
okay who's making that I don't want to
go there oh we're back here huh
interesting
it's a scratches grin see that was
horrible
hold me grizzly god damn it
please come with me hi please alright
brother I hope you enjoyed this first
episode of a Venetian machine for pigs
we got quite an adventure in the head of
us so go ahead and leave your support we
lied some comments and show that you're
there anyway stay awesome bros i'll see
in the next one
[Music]